all right welcome everybody thank you
for coming i hope you're having a great
day here of day one of nbc oslo i am
absolutely crushed that i cannot be
there with you
but
it is not all bad in the sense that uh
it is 8 20 a.m here in
phoenix arizona usa
and it is a balmy about 17 degrees
celsius outside so as soon as this
presentation is over i'm going to be
opening up all the windows in the house
and
enjoying that so uh it's not all
terrible um i am a solution architect at
uh carvana
and uh i'm i tweet at bs stall and one
of the things i just tweeted
was the uh link to the slide deck for
that the exact one that you'll be seeing
here back to see we can
kind of
hopefully you can see that zooming in
now this is a good test of the
uh
zoom capability that doesn't look like
it's going to work so
we'll have to keep that in mind i'll try
and make the fonts as big as possible
when we're looking at code
so
um
you may know me
as the guy that keeps a list of his
favorite physicists and favorite
favorite mathematicians
i see zooming did work excellent um so
that is probably all you really need to
know about me the fact that i have such
a list but there are other things that
are kind of important to know too i do
work for carvana we are disrupting the
uh used car
space here in the u.s uh we don't have
an international presence yet but for
those who are
from the us i don't expect an
international presence very soon
from carvana but it is an amazing place
so uh uh check it out if you're
in the u.s
uh i also uh
contribute to and shepherd a number of
open source projects none of these are
particularly germane to this talk uh but
there is one that may be coming out soon
i'm hoping
um
that would be very germane to this i
won't be talking about that today but
maybe next summer at
nbc oslo as well
hopefully
all right
the other thing i do is i'm one of the
founders of arizona's give camp so give
camp is an international organization
where we put a bunch of
software creators together in a room for
a weekend with a bunch of great local
charities and we code for those
charities for that weekend um and as a
former ndc
speaker has said sleep is optional
caffeine is provided
so
they are all over the place although
obviously covet has put a bit of a
damper on
much of our activities
i encourage you to check out
givecamp.org and see if there's one in
your area and if there isn't one maybe
you want to start one
feel free to ping me for information and
or advice
all right
so we're here to talk about reliability
patterns today and so we're going to use
this very very simple example
of two things that result in a
change to system state
these are two things that we need to
have happen so the example we're going
to use is sending an email and writing
a
state to the database
but these are really proxies for any two
state updates within a system so you can
think about this in any context but
these are the two examples we're going
to work with today
and our example system might look
something like this to start off with
uh it might be a
a web a user connects through a web
client to a web service
and the web service inside its web
method
sends the email and saves to the
database
and that might result in some code like
this
um
there's you know that's pretty
straightforward i mean you'll have to
kind of trust me that the code does what
it says it does although all of this
code is
in git github and is linked in the uh
slide deck that i tweeted out
so uh you do have access to all of this
code
this
particular example does a lot of the
right things it traps for errors in each
of these methods
it retries multiple times if it can't
if it doesn't do what it should do
so
it does many of the
things we would think of
so what does that result in
what we end up with is these possible
conditions
so
our happy path if everything succeeds
great we're in a perfectly good
situation and all as well
however when things don't work perfectly
what are we left with
well if our first task fails that's the
send of the email
we're probably still okay we've done
nothing
but
we've done nothing so it's okay because
we can just kind of retry later and know
what state we're in we're in a known
state we've
failed but we've failed completely
the hard part
the bad part is when we get into that
second that last box here
where
the we've sent the email
but the database update failed
now we've got a problem
now we're in a situation where
it's going to be hard to remediate it's
going to be hard to uh to do something
about it's not a good situation to be in
so what can we do about that well a
standard example something that i've
done in the past i know and i know other
people have done as well
is to say well why don't we wrap that
database call in a transaction and then
do
the email send in the middle so
something more like this
where the first step is to begin a
transaction
do the email send and then all we have
to do at the end is commit
that database transaction and we're good
that should be pretty safe right
well
let's look at what that actually results
in here first of all
we've now kind of split that middle that
middle box so in the previous one we had
a
a box where we were okay because nothing
happened
but you know we were in a known state
nothing happened now we've got two
different conditions that cause that
if the database
uh if the
begin transaction fails
nothing is done and we roll back
if the
email send fails that's fine because
we'll roll back the database
transactions so we're still good we
haven't made any state changes to the
system
but we still have this last box here
that's a real problem where
if we fail on commit
we're still in in a bad situation
now the question is how often does that
happen do we really fail on commit
and
i at least and i suspect others as well
didn't fully understand how the
service level agreements work with
our dependencies like databases it turns
out that if you look at just about any
service level agreement they're not
based on number of actions
they're based on time
how long a transaction is open or how
long any activity is open tells you how
likely it is to fail
so the longer a action is being taken
the more likely there is to be a network
failure during that time or a hardware
failure or something like that
so this because the transaction is open
for a fairly long time is actually more
likely to fail than the previous one
even though that seems counterintuitive
so where does that leave us
well
first of all we should always try to
retry we should do always assume that
our upstream is going to retry if
there's a failure so if we assume that
we've kind of got two different ways we
can treat right now in this in this
context we've got two different ways we
can treat
the
uh
our failure like we can either continue
if we fail or we can
what i called roll back here in this
which is really throwing an exception at
this point
and that's so those are listed along the
top here what these scenarios are
and then along the left side
we've got the different conditions that
we could run into where we could have
both tasks succeed both tasks fail or
combinations there up
and what we end up with is
some
some states that i just consider
[Music]
not good at all and those things that we
should never use that's continue on
either task failure or
continue with a fails but roll back if b
fails although this you could consider a
special case of this second one which is
rollback if a fails and continue with b
file so let's talk to these two that are
here in yellow the um the second column
and the fourth column
so this one the rollback if a fails and
continue if b
fails
what that does is it actually works in
most scenarios
if um and i've changed my uh my graphics
here a little bit um but the uh
if both tests succeed we're always going
to be good
but if a succeeds and b fails since
we're rolling back on a
um
and continuing on b we're going to end
up having done a but not b
but if b
you know if a fails
we're going to roll back completely
nothing will have been done and then
we'll retry it the client will be okay
so this scenario is okay
if
we don't care about action b
so i actually consider this the logging
scenario
if we're making a state change to the to
the system and
logging it or doing something else that
is not critical to the operation
then we're okay
um so i consider logging to be one of
those examples and now i'd say under
these circumstances under a situation
like logging
it's okay to do this
likewise there's this fourth column here
where
the
weirdness comes if a succeeds in b fails
and we're roll rolling back if either
task fails
what that's going to do is since a
succeeded
but b failed we're going to roll back
and we're going to try again and what
happens is a is going to get double
tapped here a is going to get executed
twice so if that's sending an email
we're going to send two emails off
this is what i consider to be the item
potent solution
and that is it's okay to do this
if this
first task
is item potent can be done over and over
again without
causing problems and we'll talk more
about item potence here in just a few
minutes
so what does this mean
knowing that
we have all these different scenarios
and if we're trying to do two things
and we can only
we have this logging scenario that's
kind of okay and we have this item
potent scenario that's kind of okay
where does that leave us with our
applications
and what it comes down to is this
it is not possible to reliably make more
than one state change to a system
in a single execution context
you can't reliably do it now it's okay
to do
if the first one is item potent the
first change is item potent or the
second change is made unreliably like in
our logging example
but if we're making two important
changes to system state
and one and neither of them is item
potent
we cannot do it reliably
so what does all that mean well let's
talk about item potentials first item
potency is one good way of of uh helping
solve these problems so let's talk about
it
item potence uh is the ability to
execute a task some arbitrary number of
times and have it be the same as if you
executed it once
so the kind of canonical example here is
these train controls
um that big green start button there the
train's off you hit the start button
train starts up hopefully
um you hit that start button again
nothing new happens because the train
remains in a started state so you can
hit that button as many times as you
want and the train is going to
remain started so it's the same as if it
executed only once the stop button is
the same way
there are a number of operations
computationally that we can do that are
item potent operations uh the absolute
value function is one
and there's actually some useful ones
too
um
so
first of all anything that's not making
a change to state
is item potent right if you're not
making a state change you can do it as
many times as you want and the state is
going to remain the same so you can
say read from a database
and that's not you know there's no
there's no state changes there so that's
an idempotent operation
another one is a database upsert
as long as you send the key along with
all the data that you
need to
upsert into the database then what
happens well the first time you execute
it if you have no data in there at all
it inserts the row
and then the next time you execute it
since you sent it the key
it will see that that key is already
there and i'll just update it and since
it's all the same data
it updates it with the same thing so
database upserts are another example of
item potent operations
these are the things that if we execute
them multiple times it's all right
so that we can use those to help us
make our systems more reliable and less
prone to failures
but what all this tells us
this um
these states and this these requirements
is that we need to try to avoid
dual rights
this dual rights anti-pattern so let's
talk about that let's figure out what
that is define it and then figure out
ways we can avoid it
so a dual right is an attempt to make
more than one reliable reliable change
to a system state
in a single invocation
now there's some words in there that
probably need to be defined so let me uh
drill into them a little
bit uh in this case what i mean by
reliable is can be expected to occur
exactly once in that context
and and really maybe it should say
once or zero times in that single
execution context you'll either know it
fails or know it succeeds one or the
other
and that of course is very dependent on
the reliability of the execution
environment and such
by change i mean an atomic operation a
topic an atomic modification so
you can change as many tables in a
relational database for example as you
want as long as it's made in a single
transaction one atomic update
and then the hardest part of this to
define
is an invocation a single invocation
what do i mean by that
and maybe the easiest way to uh
demonstrate this is with an example and
that's the say a web method
so
i'm going to send a signal an http call
to a web method
what executes between getting that call
and returning the response
to the external that's a single
invocation so it's one response to a
user signal
and if we try and do two things in there
we may have problems if one fails and
one doesn't
so we want to avoid making
one more than one reliable change or
more than one change that needs to be
reliable
to system state
in a single
invocation a single execution context
and the thing about these are these are
really difficult problems to solve when
they occur
these are usually results of hardware
changes or network failures or something
like that and of course we're all
running on on commodity hardware in the
cloud right and we have all these all
kinds of network hops in between our
actions and our users and such
um and so what ends up happening is
because they are unpredictable errors
they manifest in very different ways
when they're
when there's dual rights involved or
multiple rights involved so we could end
up with duplicated duplicated data or
missing data or missing actions
it can be
incomplete and the thing about these are
supporting these can be really really
difficult
because you don't have first of all we
don't know what they look like because
they are they're always different so
there's no way to say oh i i know i've
seen this error before because they're
all different errors generally
and our tools don't
directly support them because our tools
like if we had a web method that had
multiple act actions in it and one of
them succeeded and one of them failed we
can't just call that web method with the
proper data
because one of them already succeeded
we only need to do the other one
so our tooling is also much more
difficult so what we end up doing for a
lot of these kind of things is creating
one-off database scripts
to handle these problems to do updates
things like that
if you find yourself doing a lot of
one-off database updates
that may be a smell
that you've got this kind of problem
so something we want to avoid these are
your nights and weekends that you're
spending troubleshooting and supporting
these activities on these uh
applications
so
avoid dual rights keep it separate keep
action separate in order to keep them
safe
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to spend the rest of this talk
talking through some patterns that will
help us keep it separate
we're going to have we're going to talk
about three very similar isolation
patterns
that allow us to separate those
activities into different um execution
contexts
do them individually do one thing at a
time so that that one thing can either
succeed or fail
and then we can react to it downstream
so we're going to look at these three uh
three isolation patterns transactional
outbox change data capture and data
streaming
and then we're going to look at
the saga pattern and two different ways
to implement that
to
bring all of those together so we have
all these individual services that are
using these isolation patterns
and then we'll use these coordination
patterns to put it all together
and the all three of these isolation
patterns transactional outbox cdc change
data capture and um streaming
all really look something like this for
our example
so we still have the user that is
making a request
and that request is still stored in a
some form of a data store
i'm being in specific about what kind
here
but the big difference is
then downstream of that
is where we're going to grab that and
send the email
and all three of these patterns will do
basically this it's just the
implementation and when they're best
used
uh that changes
so let's talk about the first of these
let's talk about transactional outbox
and when i think of transactional outbox
i usually think of something like a sql
server
but many many database servers support
this kind of in fact anything i believe
where yeah any any database that you can
make and it's a uh that supports
transactions where you can make
an atomic update that has two different
components to it will work for
this um
so the goal of transactional outbox is
to reliably update a data store
and then trigger an additional action
just like we saw on the last
chart we're gonna update the database in
this case
and then we're going to trigger an
action downstream so what we do is we
make a single write to that database so
our user request comes in
and we make a single atomic write to the
database but we're going to write two
things in that transaction
we're going to write the state chains
that we want to make
and we're going to also separately write
a command
that's going to be used to execute a
secondary process
and that's what's going to be used to
send our email
it might look something like this
this is a sequence diagram and you can
see that in this case the user is making
a request from the request service
that request service updates the sql
database
uh which then
responds that it was successful
and then we have the separate email
service kind of looping in here that's
polling that sql server and saying do i
have any new messages do i have any new
commands in that out box
uh that need to be handled
and if so
it's uses that information to send the
email and then has to commit
the fact that it did
in fact send the message that it's
handled that otherwise we'll keep
getting
emails sent over and over again
now when you look at this
you may very well say um
um
isn't that doing two rights
and it kind of is um we haven't solved
the two generals problem yet
and if you're not i'm not going to go
into what the two generals problems
the problem is in this talk um i do
encourage you to do some reading on the
subject it's very interesting uh it's a
little more computer sciencey than we
tend to deal with in application
development
but it's it is kind of important to
understand that
there is still no way
to truly confirm you know
if i send you a confirmation then did
you get that confirmation are you going
to send me back a confirmation to
confirm that you got that confirmation
and then if i get that confirmation do i
um that's ultimately the two generals
problem we still have that but we're
going to have that no matter what we do
almost
so all of these patterns are still going
to be susceptible to that the idea is
that we don't need an additional one
and this is as reliable as we can
possibly make it
so let's see what that looks like in
some code and this all this code is uh
available in the github repository
let's look at the first demo this is
outbox now all of the solutions
hopefully let's see if we can drill in
on that so all of the solutions have
both services in them
a
request service which is our ingress
that's where the request comes in
and in this case it pushes that all it
pushes that out to a sql server so it
just gets that request pushes it out to
the sql server first thing do to do
get it safe get it on disk
then once it's on disk the email service
is polling for that so all we're going
to see in all three of these examples is
that the email service the thing that is
reading the results and then sending off
the email is going to be different in
how it has to handle each one those are
the biggest differences in these
patterns
so we're going to focus on that
so this is our program for our email
service and you can see that what it
does is
it it gets a service and
calls process on it
with a cancellation token
and what that does
is it loops
here until it's canceled
hopefully this is big enough that you
can see it well let's see if we can zoom
just a little more uh so it loops until
it's cancelled
and then
calls get unsent messages on the
repository so it's calling that sql
server and saying give me any unsent or
give me an unsent message if you have
one
and if it does have one
it then sends the email
and updates that the message has been
sent
pretty straightforward there right
so both of these services are very
simple
they do one and only one thing with the
exception of
the two generals problem
um
and it keeps it separate
so what does that all mean what does
that do for us
well
we have some advantages
first of all it allows us to persist
quickly and that's kind of the goal of
all of these patterns or one of the
goals of all of these patterns is to
allow us to
immediately get our requests to disk
first thing customers send you some data
get it on disk get it safe
we've got that request
and then take some action downstream
um
the outbox pattern captures every update
not every pattern that we're going to
talk about today is guaranteed to
capture every single update we'll talk
about that more when we talk about
change data capture next
and the other advantage of this is it's
very familiar tech
everybody has used relational databases
before i think uh maybe i'm just old and
i i've always used them but it to me at
least is very very familiar comfortable
technology
however
it can be very hard to both scale and to
fan out
so if you think about sql server or any
relational database
if you're going to scale the number of
email services so the downstream
if you're growing to the point where you
know what you need more than one email
server it's not likely that you'd need
more than one email processor but um
you can imagine uh downstream things
that actually require more
um capabilities
if you're gonna need to scale that out
you're gonna have to build all of the
row locking and things like that into
to make sure that only one instance of
your
service of your email service gets
that record and processes it
that's all on you
likewise if you're gonna fan it out if
you want now i don't only want to send
an email message now i also want to
take some other action send out a
message to a service boss or
something else
i'm going to have to create a whole new
processor which means i'm probably going
to need to either
create a new column in that database
that gets updated or more likely create
a new uh table that gets written to
a new outbox table that gets written to
within our transaction making that
transaction even longer
um so it's not this is not a good
pattern for scale up
or for fan out for allowing additional
you know extending the capabilities of
the application
it's also really using the database kind
of as a cue
and i've always kind of
felt kind of queasy about that um we
have tools
for
cueing and things like that maybe we
should use them
when what we're really doing is trying
to create a cue a first in first out
data structure
um as i mentioned it adds weight to the
persistence because now instead of just
persisting our state change we're also
persisting another thing that goes
inside the transaction that's our outbox
so
the longer our transactions the least
less reliable or the more opportunity
there is for failure
although because they're all in a
transaction it will roll back together
so we know we haven't done anything if
it fails
and again
like every pattern we're going to see
here
it is still susceptible to errors on the
commit phase
so uh we haven't solved two generals
with this one
all right
uh i'm keeping an eye on
the uh slido slido um
room here so if there's any questions
please please feel free to
drop them in there and i'll
do my best to answer them so i don't see
anything in there right now
all right so let's move on to
change data capture
so change data capture has a goal of
reliably updating a data store and
triggering an additional downstream
action
now if that
goal sounds familiar to you it should
because that's the exact same goal as
outbox pattern had
we're going to update the data store and
then we're going to use that to do
something downstream
in this case however
we're going to do a single atomic write
that makes one update to the database
just as we did before
the difference is instead of us creating
a separate outbox table
to help that we're going to use to
persist downstream
we're going to use the databases
features
to actually do that so the database is
going to do a lot of that work for us
um it's captures changes to the database
and then can event those out to us so
that we can use that
to process downstream actions
so what does that look like in a
sequence
well
basically the same as before in this
case i'm going to use cosmos db as the
example and that's the
example that's in the sample code in
github
so we have our request service the
request comes in there it updates the
cosmos db
all it has to do is make our state
updates
and it confirms that that's done and
then we have our separate email service
that
is actually notified now um the net
sdk
for cosmos does a great job of handling
this and unhiding a lot of the
implementation details
what really happens behind the scenes is
there is some polling going on
but from the applications perspective we
just get notified that a new message is
there
and we can handle it
so when we get notified that there's a
new message there we can send the
confirmation email and then um it gets
confirmed that the message was sent and
we commit
so let's look at the code for the back
half of that
here is our
cdc example
and so with this one now instead of
just running a loop we're actually using
a hosted service that that runs a this
cosmos change monitor
so it's looking for changes now this is
the email service so this is the back
half we've already pushed the
uh change up to cosmos
and where we see it
is in this process message async
so up here we subscribe to it
our change feed
change feed processor um this utilizes
the cosmos change feed in the cosmos sdk
and what that tells is what we're doing
here is we're giving it a delegate to
this method to this method
so when a method message comes in here
we're subscribing here saying call this
method
when we get a message
and then a message comes in in this
input so all i have to do is and it can
actually send multiple messages at once
you get to control all of that
so for each messages in the in each of
the messages in the input
logging it out deserializing it
processing it
and executing and then ending and
processing it in this case is just
turn it into an email message subject
message body and then
send the message
and we're done and with this one
um
in the uh change monitor the fact that
we processed it without throwing an
exception
the sdk then automatically
handles committing it back for us so
it's there it's just behind kind of
behind the scenes that can be hidden
so you want to know it's there
but you don't need to deal with it and
you know that if you throw an exception
in any of this processing in here inside
this method or below
it's going to roll it back and it's
going to try and send it to you again
the sdk will do that for you
so you don't have to worry about any of
those implementation details
so i consider this a much better uh a
much better implementation than
than outbox
although i don't want to make it sound
like i'm not encouraging you to use
outbox um
outbox is really useful especially if
you already have a relational database
in in
that you're making updates to and you
just want to extend that capability
outbox is a really good way of doing it
if you're starting
from ground zero with greenfield um
which we would all love to do someday
i'm sure
then
both cdc and
the next pattern that we look at
streaming are going to be really good
really good choices
all right oh make code bigger on this
one sorry i didn't do that um
hopefully you could all see what you
need and also like i said it's all there
on github
um what happens when we run more than
one instance of email service a good
question
so in this scenario
and we'll talk through this on the next
side a little bit but in this scenario
the database will do a lot of the work
for us
in balancing that load so we can spin up
multiple versions of this and as long as
we've configured it properly there's
there's a concept of a uh
what do they call those a consumer group
um
if you have multiple
applications in the same consumer group
only one
a message will be sent to one processor
in that consumer group and only one
and
the
server and the sdk handle that for you
manage all that it's beautiful
likewise you can also fan out easily
so if you have different consumer groups
you run multiple instances of this of of
consumer groups you can actually fan it
out and actually have different services
taking different actions and know that
each consumer group
will get the message once
really really useful and valuable
i hope that answered the question
so
osmo's change data capture
again we get to persist quickly
and
it's as we just discussed easy to scale
and easy to fan out because the database
and the sdk together manage a lot of
that for you
the biggest disadvantage here is that
at least with the current implementation
of cosmos db
change data capture you're not
guaranteed to capture every update
if you
make a state change and then
update that state change again very
quickly
you may see only the latest
state so it looks at the current when
it's when it's seeing the uh the changes
and you're saying oh what changes do i
have it's only going to give you the
latest state change in the current
instance of cosmos change data capture
other implementations may be different
and cosmos is actually exploring their
cosmos team is working on
um i think it's in preview right now
something where it will actually give
you every message if you choose to do so
but right now that's one of the biggest
things that you need to understand is
that it's not guaranteed to capture
every update so be aware of of your
implementation and how it works
now if you're
just writing messages so if you're
basically event streaming here where you
just throw every message into it and
you're never updating a message
then you don't have to worry about that
because you're just creating new
messages every time
and of course we are still susceptible
to
errors on that back commit of the log
you know
which it handles all for us it's all
behind the scenes but it still can fail
after it's executed the process it is
possible
however unlikely
all right the last of our isolation
patterns data streaming
goal reliably persist a message
and then trigger a different a
additional action so very very similar
in this case though we're not talking
about
necessarily a persistent state store
we want to get a message out there
and then we want of different things to
happen downstream
uh and we make a single atomic write
that puts it into that stream
and it's that stream that's used to
trigger all actions
so what does that look like in this case
well in this case i just have it pushing
into
a streaming service here
but you know the more i think about this
the more this is a little bit
disingenuous because this is not my
state update
this is not like if i'm pushing this
into say kafka or radiss or
rabbit mq
um
this is not my state update
so what i really should have is two
different services sitting down here
looping and reading these messages one
to update my database whatever that data
store is and then a separate one
to send the email so that really would
have been a better way for me to draw
this
but it's still a very very similar
process in the sense that we're pushing
a message out to
something and that thing is then going
to be used to
consume the messages and take the
downstream actions
so if there's examples of this in the
github code for both kafka and redis
using redis streaming or
kafka's streaming sdk
um this one is kafka
and so you can see just let me make it
bigger
so just like in the
cdc option we're actually using a hosted
service so that's sitting in the
background and running all the time
or this kafka change monitor now
um the kafka change monitor also
subscribes in this case it subscribes to
a what's called a topic
so messages get put into a topic
and they can fan out from there
so it subscribes to that and when it
gets a message
it calls this process message async so
very similar pattern
and then handles it
in this case just by
sending the email out
like i said i probably should have a
maybe a persistence service that's a
third one here for this example that
also writes it out to a database to make
these use cases exactly equivalent where
both of them are updating a data store
and sending an email
i hope that all makes sense
and again the code is in github so feel
free to pull it down and play with it
all right so
data streaming
again we can persist it quickly
very easy to scale and fan out all of
our
uh streaming systems are designed for
that um the one the one
that might not be easy to fan out would
be if we're just using a plain old cue
like for example azure queues or ibm
websphere queues or something like that
if we're just using a queue
that's not really good for fan out but
it's great for scale
but if we're using a topic
where it handles the fan out for you
it works great for both of them
um so kafka and redis both are
really really good for both scale and
fano
and these will capture every update
so you're to be able to get all of your
updates with with both of these you
won't you you know every message will be
seen
the uh biggest disadvantage here is that
the reliability is really subject to the
persistence of the implementation
what i mean by that is
just to contrast kafka and redis
kafka
does a great job immediately persists to
the log first thing it does is get it to
disk as quickly as it can redis very is
very dependent on how you configure it
most by default redis doesn't really go
to disk at all
and it's just kind of an in memory store
so
it's
wicked fast
but if there happens to be a hardware
failure at you know at the wrong time
redis is going to be more susceptible to
that than something like kafka
um and of course we are still
susceptible to commit errors
all right
so as you've seen these patterns are
super similar
you persist first then act on it you do
one and only one thing the only thing
you're doing in each of those things is
reacting to the signal and then
doing the specific work that that
service is designed to do
um
it's easy in cdc and streaming to fan
out
um
as well as scale
outbox and streaming both guarantee that
all changes will be sent cdc not as much
so you have to be careful there
but all are susceptible to that commit
error problem
now is there anything we can do to avoid
those commit errors
this is not going to be a satisfactory
answer yet because like i said we have
not solved
the two generals problem
we get very close to four nines with
these patterns assuming our dependencies
are supporting four nines so we can
never get better
reliability than our downstream
dependencies
or our network or hardware etc
but if we
make
proper use of item potence if we use it
wherever we reasonably can
uh it may be possible to
come very very close
to exactly what's delivery
now kafka has a specific
mechanism that they've i i'll i'll defer
you to their um
their documentation where they have a
really good write-up on
uh exactly what's delivery what it means
why they feel like the two generals
problem is not an
entirely
um
germane to that circumstance and how
they go about doing it but what it
really comes down to is still same as
what we've described do one and only one
thing do it item potently
um and then do something else downstream
uh but though there's a lot more
complexity there so we're not really
going to drill into
that in any more detail today know that
it exists
at the end of this if you're not
familiar with the concept of exactly
once delivery versus something like um
uh
at least once or at most once there is a
an appendix at the end of this slide
deck that describes what each one of
them means
all right
so we have all these isolation patterns
how do we put them together
and there's two ways
of really
putting sagas together sagas are though
that coordination of all of those
different services
we can do it through an orchestration or
we can do it through a choreography
orchestration has a single controller
a state machine generally that is
responsible for
managing everything and being a single
point of failure too
a choreography
is where all of the services are really
independent they consume messages
whatever they happen to need
transform them appropriately do whatever
their work is publish new messages out
independent of each other and not
necessarily having to know
what happens downstream so let's look at
each of those examples and see what
their
uh benefits are
so this is a saga it's kind of a
workflow
you could think about this orchestration
service as a workflow as a state machine
um
but ultimately what they're doing is
they're still it's still all
you know the user submits a request that
request is persistent as quickly as
possible
the orchestration service then
has to know i am at this point in the
process and i'm going to publish these
messages and look for
failures and look for responses and
those kinds of things from the other
services now i kind of showed them all
as different
different topics here different uh buses
but it really it could be one bus as
well
i don't tend to do that but it uh it's
something that can be done if if need be
but what this is doing is at least these
first two steps are the same as what
we've done before the orchestration
service is going to notify we need to
update the database it's going to
send out the email
and then it's also got notifications
going to billing and
the request action service so if this
service what is if what it's allowing
the users to do is request us to do
something hey i'd like i need you guys
to go and do this thing
uh we can send them the confirmation
email write it out
send some information you know charge
them for it as appropriate and then send
it off to whomever is actually doing the
work probably fiverr right something
like that um
and then
if this comes back and says sorry we
can't do that
for some reason the orchestration
service then is responsible for saying
ah we couldn't service your request
let's send a compensating request back
to the billing service to say give you
your money back
so that's the kind of orchestration
we're talking about here
however
choreography i've labeled as my ideal
architecture this is where i prefer to
go
because
we've come a long way in the last 10
years and and what i see this as is this
is what i refer to as the microservices
pattern
this is what i see as a good
implementation of microservices you have
simple services where all they're doing
is one and only one thing one change to
state of the system
they're independent
they
read from some data source
transform manage do their one thing
and publish some message
and they do so kind of independent of
what everything else needs so i know i
need to react to this stimulus i need to
react to some particular message the
upstream may not know that i'm
responding to it
i do my work i publish a message out
i don't have to know what downstreams
are using that all i know is i publish
my canonical example my canonical
structure
that says here is my message here's the
thing i've done or here's what you need
to know about or you know generally what
what someone downstream might need to
know
about this thing
and then i don't worry about it
this i think is an ideal pattern
there is nothing more powerful that i've
experienced
than
needing to augment a system needing to
add a feature to a system
and already having something a a trigger
an event in the system that i can
subscribe to
that is exactly what i need to then go
off and build that additional feature
that's how we make systems that are
extensible
because any whatever is doing its work
is publishing these messages out
and i can find the appropriate trigger
that i need to then do
whatever it is i need to do in this
inside the system the additional work i
need to do inside the system
but that comes with a caveat
that additional thing
should never be just kind of added on
there is always this
tendency this this
i don't know it's like if you think
about i need to add a feature here
well i've already got this thing that's
doing something that's going to trigger
it why don't i just plug that right
inside
that existing context
and you're going to get pressure from
your
your analysts your product people to say
well just plug it in there
but this is your nights and weekends
that they're telling you to get to
sacrifice to support that thing because
if you add on inside an execution
context you are creating a dual right
and you're creating a situation where
there are going to be difficult
problems to solve at some point it may
not happen often it may not happen for a
while
but at some point it's going to happen
and then you're going to have to spend
the effort to figure out hey what
happened and then how do i fix it
so never add on never add on
all right
so let's sum up here we're just about
out of time
so
it is impossible to reliably take two
actions inside a single execution
context i know i haven't fully proven
that to you yet in an hour it's kind of
difficult to prove
know that i absolutely believe that that
with as much scientific certainty as i
can
as i can give you
and that is
i know that there is no such thing as
certainty but i'm confident
um
so we can't do it so
avoid taking multiple all making
multiple state changes to systems in a
single context break them up
uh the best practice is always
persist first get a message persistent
then take other actions as necessary
ideally in a separate execution context
we can use outbox cdc change data
capture or streaming to help isolate our
the different features of our
applications the different things that
need to change the state of the system
we prefer it's better to use cdc or
streaming for best fan out and
scalability but outbox is a perfectly
good pattern especially if you already
have
sql server or some equivalent in the mix
where you're already populating state
and then consider how you're going to do
your sagas
to either orchestrate or choreograph
these complex
interactions reliably
we have some really you know i mean
we've come a long way in terms of our
tools to monitor
our sagas that was always the biggest
concern at the beginning of the
microservices era was how do we manage
we have all of these different services
out here sure they're simple and easy to
deal with and easy to deploy and easy to
work on independently
so i can have lots i can scale my team
i can deploy them out frequently all of
these great benefits we get from these
small micro services
but how do we
follow a single request through the
system and
we know there are certain things that
we'll have to do there we're going to
have to put like
correlation ids on every request
to be able to follow them through but
then with shared logging tools and tools
like app insights or app dynamics or
whatever it is you're you're
you're using we can actually get even
visualizations of the interactions of
our systems and see where there are
problems and see what's causing
difficulties and
using the
correlation id we can go into our shared
logs and actually see across all of our
different services
here is
all of the logging for that
correlation id so we can get a full
picture
of the log of all of our services and we
can see a picture of the interactions of
all of our services and how they work
together
and what's causing problems
with these tools
i think we've solved all of the problems
all of the big problems anyways
and the problem that we still need to
solve is
avoiding these dual rights so we can
avoid spending our nights and weekends
figuring out these complicated problems
so
avoid the urge resist
don't add on
and keep everything separate
one
change per execution context
here's some resources
i do work for carvana
uh as i said uh the code samples are
linked here
uh article on item potence articles on
each of the three isolation
patterns some
some
specifics on the
on ways to do streaming
as well as
stuff on the saga pattern and this is
the actual article that
got me started going down the path of
why
our service level agreements don't
actually you know
why it is
that our
transactions don't make things more
reliable they actually make them less
relaxed so i encourage you to read that
it's a little off the bottom of the
screen here but there's also an article
down at the bottom on
the plant uml tools because that is
there's diagrams in each of those code
that use plant uml to show you the
sequence diagrams that i showed
so that's there as well
and all of that can be garnered either
by going to my twitter account at bs
stall and clicking on this link or by
shooting this
and
pulling down that slide deck and being
able to just click directly on all of
those links
i don't see any additional questions on
here but it looks like we have three
more minutes so i will
happily hang out and answer any
questions that you might have and
other than that i thank you for
attending and hope you have a great
conference
you